jennifer how are you this morning i'm
doing well i hope you are thank you for
taking my call
hey thank you so much for calling in how
can i help
so about well most of my life i've had
some mental health issues and about five
years ago
i went and sought help and got on
medication
and it seems to be working pretty well
but my question is
ever since i was younger my i've kind of
gotten the impression from my parents
that they don't necessarily believe in
medications that it's more
of a mindset and i'm trying to figure
out a way to
open those communications with them and
let them know what's going on with me
and on the flip side i have a 15 year
old daughter that i would like to
open those lines of communications up
with as well
that's awesome that's some good stuff
here okay so number one why do you feel
like you need to tell your parents
what's going on
well honestly i think my mom might have
some issues that she could
talk to somebody benefit from talking to
somebody about but
truthfully i am a single mom and my mom
and dad
are my um emergency contacts okay
and if something was to go wrong you
know they need medical issues and things
like that i don't want them to ever be
surprised if something comes up
do you think something's going to come
up no no
but at the same time you know it's just
one of those things that
i would like for us to have the open
communication for them
i don't know i i kind of i guess i want
my parents approvals
on things like this ding ding ding ding
so here's the deal
there's a fantasy with that one that
you're gonna have to let go
okay and the sooner you can put that one
down
and let it just flutter off like a
butterfly my guess is
that will be one of the first steps
towards you
having healing in your heart and mind
okay um you're not gonna get their
approval on this one
is my guess gotcha
if they are and i know folks like this
they've got good hearts
i don't think they're evil they just
think mental health is a crock
they think that um anybody taking them
galdurn pills
is just a knucklehead or weak or a wimp
or whatever
right and they're you're just not gonna
change their mind
you're gonna they're gonna get defensive
you're gonna get defensive you're gonna
feel hurt you're not gonna get the
approval that you were seeking and it's
just gonna
it's gonna be three steps back for your
own wellness and so the biggest gift you
can give yourself is to take them out of
your box and what i mean by that is you
should have a box of people
three or four of them at the most maybe
five if you're if you're crazy
and they're the ones who get to speak
into your life
and i do have that i do have friends
that you know i i do share that with and
things like that i just
i guess i also want to be able to open
it up with my daughter and if my
daughter brings it up to my parents
because they have a pretty open
relationship as well sure so
this is that's a whole other
conversation i 1000
think you should sit down with your
daughter and be honest and open
okay i think that's a wonderful gift
that a mother can pass along to her
daughter
this idea especially a single mom here's
some of the challenges i've gone through
here's some of the things i'm doing to
take care of myself to put my oxygen
mask on first
how to take care of myself so that i'm
whole so i can take care of you and love
you the way you deserve to be loved
but more importantly to model it you can
tell her everything you want but after
you all have a series of conversations
you teach her about what's going on in
your heart and head
then she's going to watch it closely and
she's going to learn from you
what a strong brilliant powerful
awesome woman does when she's struggling
right and they don't go to war with
people
who they're not gonna it's just gonna be
futile
right they don't try to convince people
that don't want to be convinced
they don't invite themselves into
conversations that they know is gonna
end painful
and painfully um and so yeah i would let
your mom and dad go
don't cancel relationships with them
like they were just talking about no no
no
we have a great relationship um they're
great parents and everything like that
i've just always gotten the impression
that
they don't think the way i do on this
topic
sure and so i i think a key for you is
to
make peace with it in your heart and
then if it comes up naturally because i
i'm getting from your call you don't
feel super sold on it
and when we don't feel super sold we
feel we feel like we go tell other
people
in our lives and we rally them around to
our way of seeing things
and it helps us feel better about what
we're doing and so
if you're finding peace and you're
finding wellness
and you're working with a counselor or a
physician towards taking care of
yourself
then go with that trust the
professionals there and
go with it and then if it comes up
naturally in conversation you can be
like oh yeah mom i've been in counseling
for a while
i went through a divorce just kind of
nailed it on the head with the whole
getting piece with myself about it i
i never thought of it that way yeah you
have lingering
you're carrying some of their baggage
with you right
so can i just can we can i ask you
something i tend to think
anxiety depression those those are just
signals they're alarm systems
right that tell me one of three things
i'm disconnected my relationships are
busted
i am um
not safe something in my ecosystem is
telling me i'm not safe and it may be
childhood traumas that are rear in their
heads
or i'm out of control i'm in a situation
where i can't control anything
and i don't i don't feel like it's going
to end well why are your
alarms going off probably the latter the
out of control and
needing to get more control when did you
start spinning out
honestly when i was i remember being
really young
and thinking about reaching out to
psychiatrists and things like that back
when i was a teenager did you grow up in
a
chaotic situation no no my parents were
great
my everything was great um
maybe i kind of felt that
i was luckier than most people but
with things like that but no no nothing
that i can recall at all
that's fantastic and so you find
yourself a single mom
working through it i think you are um
i mean you're being brave you've got to
trust your counselor you've got to trust
your doctor
and then you've got to have an open
dialogue with your daughter
have an open dialogue with a daughter be
a great teacher be a mom
not a friend you're her mom but be a
great teacher be a great
modeler and then just love your parents
for who they are
they're going to have their thoughts on
things if they invite you into a
conversation be honest of course
if they say hey what is all this about
this counseling stuff we hear about on
the internets
every once in a while you can say
mom i've been in counseling for a while
and it's it's extraordinary
or if they make if they say what do you
think about this medication i think it's
nonsense
you can say anxiety medication helps
turn the alarms down a little bit
it helps turn the alarms down a little
bit so that i can
actually do the hard work of getting
well i'm not going to be on them forever
but they really do help turn that
sharpness down just so i can actually
hear a counselor i can start hearing
relationships i can start trusting
myself again
i can connect fully with my daughter
because i don't have both hands over my
ears trying to protect myself from these
alarms
man you're talking about legacy change
there you're talking about
really changing the way your daughter
grows up jennifer the way she sees her
mom the way she sees herself the way
she's going to see her daughters
that's a brave brave move vulnerability
requires courage and bravery
and it's the right thing to do good for
you jennifer good for you
you're a good mom love your parents for
where they are
and be about changing your daughter's
tomorrow invest in her teach her about
you
and you're gonna change your hearts and
mind good for you